this is Startalk Oliver Sacks wrote this
book and anthropologist on Mars okay and
that title refers to Temple Grandin
which i think is cool because it first
it references Mars but for any other
reason and it also references that Mars
had a civilization it says though you
are you are from another planet and then
everything else is is a fresh
observation for you right and watching
people behave and conduct themselves if
you otherwise have no idea what people
are doing with one another and you're
simply observing it right that is the
most unbiased scientist you can be as an
observer of cultures that's an
interesting perspective yeah would you
agree yeah IBP as simple as saying she
just couldn't understand what people
were doing when they were interacting it
comes naturally to people who don't know
she doesn't layer her own expectations
right knowledge right presumptions right
in fact we have to do that Oh does she
like me does she not like me did she
look in my direction yeah because it's
the social cues that lets you know that
you fell across the line you're now a
stalker that's right but the social cues
not only let you know when you cross the
line they also tell you if you didn't
see it coming right right right there's
a cue that you should have picked up on
and you did right yeah and yes exactly
it's just like you know like why why
isn't he getting that I want him to ask
me out right now why I'm using a guy
that's guys I don't know that's well why
that just okay but you know what I'm
saying this is Startalk